ces trois mères juives qui sont copines
donc Rebecca Rachel et bah comment elle
s'appelle ta mère voilà très important
pour la suite donc Rebecca
je pouvais éviter les blagues
antisémites ce soir tu vas voir Rebecca
Rachel et serre donc c'est trois copines
elles sont fiers de leur fils parce
qu'ils gagnent plutôt bien leur vie et
tout et Rebecca elle dit moi de toute
façon les filles mon fils il est
tellement riche mais s'il veut et ben il
peut racheter tout Paris alors Rebecca
elle fait elle prend les boules un peu
donc elle dit moi Rebecca mon fils il
est tellement riche que s'il veut et ben
il peut racheter tout New York et là il
y a Esther qui dit les filles qui vous a
dit que mon fils vont
c'est pas mal
aussi alors
ressemblance entre une blonde et une
tortue
pourtant j'en connais beaucoup
[Applaudissements]